la maison a eu elle y a tout d'un centre
de loisirs classique à une chose près
elle s'occupe d'enfants en situation de
handicap mental ou de troubles du
spectre autistique
on a voulu
poursuivre l'inclusion que l'on fait
déjà sur le temps scolaire donc
évidemment avec l'éducation nationale on
a quatre classes ulis sur la ville de
montigny s'il n'y a rien pendant les
vacances ils peuvent pas être accueillis
sur le centre municipal de l'heure de
leur commune en fait la stimulation et
l'accompagnement stagne j'accompagne mon
fils amine qui a 8 ans est un enfant
autiste avec un développement de retard
accompagné par une éducatrice
spécialisée et une animatrice formés aux
problématiques du handicap la maison
propose de multiples activités adaptées
et d'étangs d'inclusion avec les autres
enfants du centre de loisirs on va faire
beaucoup d'activités manuelles pour
qu'ils puissent toucher différentes
textures on va faire des sorties à
l'extérieur donc on a un partenariat
avec le pôle sciences où on va en forêt
il nous faut découvrir plein de choses
en forêt avec les enfants et ça marche
très bien aujourd'hui c'était le jour de
la décoration de la salle et de la mise
en place de toutes les tous les ateliers
axés sur noël la difficulté c'est la
sociabilisation et de se rapprocher des
autres enfants ça c'est une grande
difficulté pour ces enfants là et ils
n'ont pas encore les codes des outils et
en fait ici on leur apporte c'est qu'au
delà ces outils-là des activités qui
portent déjà leurs fruits et qui
réjouissent les parents soucieux du
bien-être des enfants mais également de
se poser quelques instants les familles
sont confrontées à des difficultés entre
la gestion de leur vie de famille de
leur vie professionnelle
et c'est vrai que ça leur permet pour
les familles un moment de répit
aujourd'hui à des enfants qui parlent
qui nous disent voilà ça va pas j'ai mal
ici où j'ai envie de faire ça alors
qu'avant c'était compliqué pour avoir
recours à ce service il suffit
d'adresser une demande par courrier au
service scolaire de la ville la ville de
montigny va également accueillir la
fondation à mme de gaulle dans les mois
à venir pour accompagner des personnes
trisomiques et leurs familles dans le
quartier du village